salve oggi è il momento che un vero
videogiocatore aspetta per tutta la vita
e il momento di the scatolare dio questa
scatola gigantesca che la cosa che
notiamo subito di questa scatola e il
nastro adesivo danger che come se stessi
riscatto lando una bomba pensa che l'ha
consegnato sono e sta cagando sotto
prova berets se chi lo consegnava se
avesse saputo lasciare dentro un casino
andiamo ad e scatolare questa perla
chiamata ps5 conosciuta anche come
motivo di rottura delle relazioni da
partire dalle 19 a pavia 19 novembre è
un sacco di razioni finiranno la mia
prima allora andiamo ad aprire dei
signori allora come tirare fuori questa
cosa tecniche si vede che non facciamo
attività si vede però per questo è il
momento che tutti me compreso aspetterò
mamma la mamma ai per suo figlio
crediamo di the scatolare la perla
finora abbiamo visto tutto online e il
momento al raid online
allora abbiamo in apertura proprio della
scatola troviamo si emoziona quel
soffitto 2 all sense fai fai lo dico io
ma è bellissimo
puoi trovare la sì certo
sabi il corpo di marina sì sì salute
c'è anche un pizzico di demon's soul è
bello perché è un po pc 18 ce lo senti
proprio sul sul palmo senti bella roba
però le relazioni finiranno ancora prima
quindi il 2 del sens lo mettiamo 40 dopo
arriva luca dell'ometto propri loro
appoggio
dopodiché abbiamo alimentatore classico
libretto delle istruzioni che
alla base per tenerle in verticale
io non la terrò in verticale ragazzi
anche per l'orizzonte si questa si gira
un modo tecnologia cavo hdmi e cavo tait
si sa per
dopodiché o non c'è niente voto
all'interno andiamo cav h
allora le uova se le sono mangiate ma è
rimasto è rimasto all'interno tutto a
posto
ok mi ha fatto male il cuore in questo
momento bravo va bene fa nulla tataratà
metti la musica non l'ha molto io
stupido metti fa vj del futuro una
musica incredibile no copyright
[Musica]
abbiamo la nostra playstation 5 che è
titanica vedo se riesco a fare quella
roba che ho visto fare con l'occhio di
sauron qua rossa e anche questa ciccioso
però tanto non la tocco che controlla
rajaa è vero che questo disco perché c'è
anche quella senza disco un bar e gli
attacchi sul retro 2 usb 3.0 le ethernet
hdmi ha inventato signori questo è il
futuro
protestiamo che dite
[Musica]